A lot of companies try to take their construction toys...
...and make them pink to appeal to girls.
And while, yeah, it's true, girls do like pink,...
...I think there's a lot more to us than that.
So, I've spent the last year researching this.
How do you get girls to like a construction toy?
It all kinda came down to one simple thing:...
...boys like building and girls like reading.
It says here, "Do you know the girl named Goldieblox?"
"She likes to think outside the box."
So I came up with a really simple idea:...
...what if I put those two things together?
Spatial plus verbal, book series plus building set.
How long's the ribbon?
I took the story and my prototype and I tested it with over a hundred kids.
We got it!
Daddy! You have to watch this.
And that's how Goldieblox was born.